in universities my universities and
every other university
it's now being run by the daiso czars
right so professorships are granted
not based on the merit of your cv
but it is based on whether you have the
right identity markers
one of which since we're talking about
gender gap and so on one of which is
you know some professorships you are
officially not allowed to apply
unless you are a woman or you
self-identify as a woman that's not
satire this is
literally true don't apply right
it's well first of all you wonder how is
that not illegal but now here's the
here's the little rub 100 years ago we
had institutional
you know sexism whereby women were
denied equal access to
education in which case that was wrong
and we've corrected it
now today here is the data that i'd like
to report to your viewers
in the u.s if you take five races
so black white hispanic uh you know
native american i can't remember the
fifth one
so across five races and four
levels of education so in the u.s you
have what's called an associate's degree
which is half a bachelor's then you have
a bachelor's degree
then you have master's then you have
doctoral so you have five races
by four educational levels so there are
20 cells
guess how many of the cells do
women outnumber men you follow the
question so there are 20 cells
you get how many of those cells okay
let's do it the other way actually
how many of the cells do men outnumber
women
i just i had my answer right now you've
flipped it and said um
i would say that
women will outnumber men
i think women outnumber men in in the
20s
you're exactly correct i guess maybe i
set it up in such a way that you were
going to go this way
now if it were that we need programs
to protect women in university it should
be what it was a hundred years ago which
is if we took this exact same
data matrix 20 out of the 20 cells it
would be men outnumbering
women and we need to redress that well
today
not 100 years ago across every race
and every educational level women
outnumber
men so what is the logical conclusion of
what we should do
we need more programs to protect
women because brah misogyny
okay so this is what an idea pathogen
does to your brains it says i don't give
a [ __ ]
about this racist thing called data
and facts and science and numbers i care
about
a victimhood narrative and there is no
amount of evidence that you could give
me
that you can deny the fact that women
are afraid to walk
on campus because of daily gang rapes
right
so now that doesn't mean that i don't
support by the way i was asked to
appear at a business school luncheon or
whatever
to give a talk on how i am a better
ally to women guess how that
conversation went
uh i said no i'm not an ally to women
i'm an ally to all individuals i have
been an ally to women
i have been an ally to men i have been
to ally to people who are purple
who are white who are fat who are short
i judge people based on the merits of
who they are
so then i said but i'm willing to come
and talk about evolutionary based sex
differences
oh let us get back to you professor that
they never got back to you i know for a
fact
well they got back and said sorry we're
going another direction
right so why should i support that
victimhood narrative i mean
my dean who's a fantastic uh person is a
woman
the the the uh the associate dean of
research is a woman
the head of my department is a woman
some of the
recent research professorships are all
women
so guess what let's find a way to be
better
allies to women that makes no sense
right so
how about we stop with the victimhood
narrative drop all this die religion
[ __ ] and go back to an ethos of
individual dignity
you